alors que le monde entier est en train
de se battre pour trouver le vaccin le
plus efficace pour lutter contre la
copie 19 la solution pourrait bien se
trouver ailleurs
1re espoir une plante venue de
guadeloupe appelé l'arbre de pique
elle permettrait aux cellules de se
protéger et d'être totalement hermétique
au virus
autre espoir le spray nasal exaucé des
24 développé par le centre médical
design à vichy loeb qui auraient la
capacité d'éliminer 99 à 8 9% des
bactéries présentes dans le nez une
solution qui laisse de nombreuses aux
airelles sceptiques à lille c'est un
matheux tueur de virus qui fait beaucoup
parler
le masque si d'altesse des laboratoires
bio serenity grâce à ses quatre courses
dont certains habib et d'un agent actif
serait capable d'empêcher le virus de
passer de procéder éliminerait 99,9 pour
cent du virus en cinq minutes
alors croyez vous remède miracle contre
lacko bide alors ça 19h52 on en direct
et ça on a tous envie d'avoir des
réponses assez incroyable cette histoire
avant qu'on ait les réponses de jean
michel
je sais qu'il y en a qui ont bien sûr
enquêter donc quand je dis enquête bien
entendu je parle pas d'eux alors audio
genton voilà moi j'y crois beaucoup
et à chaque fois on nous rétorque y a
pas eu d'essais cliniques
c'est ça qui m'énerve mais par exemple
je prends l'exemple de madagascar le
présent de madagascar alors c'est
madagascar à la casse car il fait des
tisanes à l'armoise il a refusé le
vaccin et y'a pas plus d'explosions de
cas à madagascar qu'ailleurs donc je
demande
je pense que vous souscrivez mon cher
médecin qu'il y ait des essais cliniques
pour ce spray qui effectivement ne
élimine si vous voulez la gravité sterk
quand on se met ça dans le nez eh bien
il n'y a plus de gravité du coup il
paraît qu'il faut lui boîte un oui mais
limite mes yeux j parce qu'ils ne
croient pas aux vaccins quand il ya des
essais il n'ya pas des essais il dit ah
mais là c'est bon ça va marcher la
tisane de chevaux oui il ya cumul sur
les réseaux sociaux plein de remettre
complètement farfelu alors mes larmes et
de chameau rien à voir mais ses sorties
au dernier confinement c'est vrai mais
dans la lah
la ce a rien à voir là c'est vrai
l'efficacité du médicament n'a pas
complètement validé mais sachez que
c'est en rupture de stock en guadeloupe
et en martinique
pareil ça marche à fond oui il parait
qu'il ya plein de gens qui disent que ça
marche
alors vous aussi vous a manqué pourquoi
est ce qu'on croit au remède miracle
parce que les vaccins ne sont pas
fiables à 100% tous les jours on lit que
tel ou tel vaccin n'est pas efficace sur
telle ou telle variante donc je
comprends que les gens s'intéressent ce
remède miracle qui a eu d'autres maîtres
mairat qui ont été évoquées dans les
médias y avait aussi la vitamine d et le
zinc je crois que michel si je me trompe
pas donc si les vaccins étaient fiables
à 100% et qu'on nous rassurer tous les
jours dans les médias on ne croirait pas
à ça alors on est obligé d'y croire
guillaume je vais même bénigne de vaccin
efficace vous dire de ne feriez pas de
baquet de vaccin efficace à 100%
n'existe pas mais arrête de dire parce
qu'en disant ça tu réellement territoire
ennemi de dieu que dire c'est la
recherche des vaccins en grenat varillon
on nous dit qu'un tel vaccin n'est pas
efficace sur les barres ya aucun lien
aucun ballon dans l'axé
bon sang mais c'est marion nommera qui
soit efficace apparemment mais arrête de
m'appeler n'ont pas été gâtés c'est une
bêtise fait les vaccins ont fait de la
télévision pas de la vaccination
merci pas tout de suite delphine les
gens se tournent de plus en plus vers le
naturel donc c'est formidable a lancé
les remèdes de grand-mère les plantes
donc si ça fonctionne c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle et on parle trop peu
aussi de comment booster ses défenses
immunitaires le fait de faire du sport
ça protège ça protège de ne pas avoir
cette maladie et ça on n'en parle pas
assez ou très bien le masque michael joo
lit et mixe et ne l'a fait ben ali
devenu à ce que je vais dire que depuis
mars
merci matin et soir je me mets du spray
nasal
mais depuis mars et franchement pour
booster mais mes défenses immunitaires
et inconsciemment dans ma petite tête je
me dis que ça aide pour la corrida et
donc il ya du sodium les bougies à la
fenêtre cadix et n'importe quoi lors
jean michel comme nombre des
responsables
le spray nasal il est à l'essai pour le
moment en fait c'est l'eau ionisée et on
pense que si on pulvérise cet audio
knees et à l'intérieur du nez on va
pouvoir empêcher la pénétration du virus
donc très probablement que ce spray
nasal va marcher
le problème c'est bien de fois il faudra
le faire dans la journée
est ce que ça marche sur laissés pour
compte à ce 200 points le fait deux cent
fois oui mais est-ce que c est ce que
pour la bouche ça protégera quelque
chose ça on sait pas donc on attend
effectivement vérité concernant le
vaccin guillaume le vaccin de la grippe
fonctionne aujourd'hui à 60% pas plus
c'est à dire on sait quand on vaccine
conte à 60 bossant de gens qui sont
immunisés mais on n'a pas les autres
miss mayotte parce que l'immunité
collective les protège aujourd'hui on a
des vaccins qui protège à 98 5% pour le
talent pour le finder qu'à 95 voire 97
pour moderna et astrazeneca tout n'est
pas clair encore mais ça protège quand
même donc il faut se faire vacciner
c'est la seule solution maintenant après
il ya les autres produits après il ya
les poudres de perlimpinpin pas il ya
les produits alors quand on parle des
remèdes naturels un remède naturel en
principe il faut qu'ils contiennent une
substance à l'intérieur et que cette
substance elles sont efficaces pour tuer
le virus si elle tue pas le virus ça
sert à rien donc jean-michel cohen juste
il ya en israël par exemple il paraît en
train aussi de développer un spray nasal
qui lui serait capable de guérir du
coronavirus en apaisant le système
immunitaire des patients
plus impressionnant encore toujours
selon ces tests 29 des 30 passion aurait
guéri dans les trois à cinq jours qui
ont suivi le début du traitement
et c'est vrai qu'à ça le spray nasal on
dit qu'c'est sait capable d'éliminer 99
% de la charge virale de notre marine
donc ce spray nasal ou ne rien c'est pas
du pipi de chat alors il ya le spray
nasal l'inhalateur en israël il protège
surtout aujourd'hui sur les trente
personnes qui ont été étudiées alors il
est contestée parce qu'il ya eu 30
placebo à côté mais il protège
apparemment des formes graves c'est à
dire que les gens qui étaient
hospitalisés en forme grave en 24 à 48
heures d'après les chercheurs qui ont
mis au point ce système en 48 heures il
arrive à récupérer la forme grave et il
faut sortir les gens de l'hôpital
beaucoup plus tôt que d'habitude tous et
toutes ces choses là elle nécessite
quand même une vérification à un moment
donné une approbation et tout le monde
est impatient de trouver quelque chose
si bien que chacun à son grigri
oui allez lire nathalie elle met son
spray qui était lui mairie
du rouge au stade y met du rouge à wall
a ramené à merci vaporub le vicks
vaporub agencé gicla je m'en mets tout
le temps et des fois je me suis dit
tiens si ça se trouve ça mais il y avait
un rôle mais il y avait aussi très beau
début d'émission
si on fait quand il ya quelqu'un qui dit
les choses intéressantes on se retourne
on les dit bravo et merci bravo bernard
montiel le porte parole du gouvernement
bris alors l'herbe à cliquer que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure ça vient des
ratés attention à pas mettre entre
toutes les mains
vous savez alors c'est de tradition
millénaire ben saada des mayas vous
imaginez bien sûr et ses traités aux
antilles n'a pas toujours mais ça se
trouve le long des routes aux antilles
et figurez vous que c'est très bon
non seulement beau contre les fièvres
contre la grippe mais enfin en fait ça
empêche le développement du virus
et c'est très bon c'est pour vous c'est
intéressant c'est un très bon vermifugés
et puis c'est contre les essais quand on
est malade on réalise un bon vernis
non mais c'est vrai un docteur cohen
comme 50 noeuds ça fait aller alors tous
les bois du pea se sont jetés sur le
verra pic l'an passé les rebelles
appellent ça le débat pic
il a été donné dans pleins dédication
l'asthme les allergies la fatigue etc
et le gars qui propose ça à l'heure
actuelle la personne qui propose ça
c'est quelqu'un qui nie que ça empêche
la multiplication du virus est ce un
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas de
démonstration me dit qu'il veut la
vérité monde a envie de trouver son
petit truc a demandé c'était un nicotine
il y avait des gens qui suçait façon
compulsive ça c'est nicotine despaties
nicotine et en pensant que la nicotine à
les protéger donc ça tu ça montre
simplement le niveau de peur de la
population et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
se vacciner s'il vous plaît j'aimerais
qu'on ait la vie de ratrapper
[Rires]
chaque jour deux virus donc je pense
qu'effectivement il savoir remède à tous
sur ce virus c'est ça qui est bien alors
oui j'ai deux questions au dr
on rit vous riez vous prononciez le mot
gris gris mais si dans certains pays je
citais madagascar d'autres pays
darrigade et d'irm à la casse car c'est
mon ma prononciation et dj mais avec le
nez s'affaisser haoussa à madagascar
[Rires]
madagascar et dans certains pays
d'afrique par exo à dakar dans les
tropiques ça ne se développe pas est-ce
que c'est pas parce que les gens
justement on césaire de ses produits
qu'ils utilisent depuis longtemps on
s'en moque mais est ce que c'est parce
que les restaurants sais rien mais tout
ça c'est fait vous le font des gets pas
la médecine traditionnelle
guadeloupéenne on va pas la jeter
certes on peut de façon inopinée trouver
un produit une substance qui va
fonctionner mais il faut pas se
contenter de dire que ça marche pour en
vendre
il faut dire que ça marche parce qu'on
avait hérité que ça guérissait les gens
c'est assez sale pas la garde nous votre
coach qui arrive je vous le dis alors
écoutez bien ça y est start up française
qui aurait également développé un masque
filtrant et des contaminants une
entreprise qui fabrique des masques pour
santé publique sans que ça a révélé
cette semaine avoir mis au point un
masques à usage unique utilisant une
couche textile tueuse de virus selon les
études menées le masque aurait montré
une réduction du virus de 99 9%
donc c'est énorme en moins de cinq
minutes est de 99 96 % au moins de deux
heures
ce dispositif fonctionnera sur les
variants selon l'inserm
donc ça c'est pas mal du tout alors avec
ses brésil non c'est vrai c'est vrai il
ya deux types de masques aujourd'hui qui
sont intéressants c'est celui là qui
vient de sortir parce qu'il faut
rappeler que les masques protègent entre
80 et 90 7% se vante selon le type de
masque qu'on utilise parce que il sert à
protéger l'autre et il sert à protéger
de l'autre
m selon l'ema ses 80 à 90 7 % maximum et
là on a un masque qui protégerait 99.5
bon sens parce qu'il serait en quelque
sorte virucide sa vieille tueur et le
virus très il ya deux types de masques
qui sont intéressants celui là qui a
l'air simple et facile à porter et il ya
les masques qui contiennent des fils
d'argent à l'intérieur et en fait les
fils d'argent permettent également
d'arrêter le virus
donc ce sont mes sauf que celui la bête
d'argent sad à cotonou
je crois 25 25 16 25 euros
cela vaudra 1 euro 50 mais c'est des
masques intéressant celui là est
probablement très intéressant parce
qu'il est moins cher est beaucoup plus
facile à porter donc ça c'est une très
très bonne idée
delphine oui mais là cette substance
c'est qu'avec une substance chimique qui
vu les russes donc on y note on l'avait
la journée sur le visage
ah ouais pas mal bonnes questions là je
l'avais dresse là et pas celle là en
principe on n'est pas censé inhalé un
produit quand il est imprégné et donc
comme c'est des produits qui sont à la
limite qui tue le virus ça sera pas si
grave que ça le consommer dans l'air
ambiant partout il ya quand même des
substances environnementale qui vous
menacent donc si vous commencez à
raisonner comme ça on peut rien faire
mais la réflexion des pertinent pour
résumer à 20 heures le spray nasal à mal
c'est pas nul le sait pas nul non pas du
tout on en trouve ou parce que j'ai
envie d'en acheter tout il n'est pas la
commercialiser il attend l'autorisation
mais il va l'être vraiment dans les
prochaines semaines la jambe donc wells
avec la revue vers le rez ouais bah
c'est sûr
ouais alors l'arbre à pic puisque c'est
bon ça et ben écoutez vous pouvez le
prendre parce que c'est pas bien ça sans
rien mon avis a fallu chercher de les
arbres à pique mon nom ça c'est l'herbe
à pic
l'herbe à pinon le monde ah ouais là bas
on les mangera en décoction mais en fait
ils vont vendre le médicament il
s'appelle verra pique en bois diallo
médicaments et rapide et donc tous les
bailleurs et la rupture de stoney
terapeak que bienvenu ouvrira billets
chez des rats dans les ira car massive
et rapide
bienvenue et donc le masque bien aussi a
bien mais bien sûr cela il ya trois
trucs pour qu on se fait chier comme il
y en a d'autres
on a d'autres il ya maintenant une
société française qui a du mal à se
faire homologuer vraiment sont produits
à l'étranger et qui fait ce qu'on avait
les anticorps plone polyclonaux samash
vallès ont fait une injection et en fait
on envoie des anticorps chez le man
c'est comme ça que très soignée c'est
pas des anticorps polyclonaux saints
cyrille et monaco les vosgiens et à quoi
les anticorps monoclonaux son email
haïssent ils ont développé des folies
que excusez moi on va dire des îles
grecques comme ça
et il ya des il ya des corps des mycoses
de mykonos
alors oui donc confirmé qu'il faut il
vaut mieux avoir donc un évident qu'un
échec
non oui absolument cela way salle alors
ça c'est ça c'est une info il vaut mieux
avoir un ennemi la truffe humide ou
tonné le ni ni lui ni son domicile à
l'intérieur et lessive en fait sont des
protecteurs nom et donc comme ça font
raser les poils du zen alors si un petit
peu pour faire de la télé mais à ce que
je sache décideront qu'on se force pas à
le faire mais quand on a le nez qui suit
un diamant c'est un jour les signes sont
progression et c'est un mec avant un
gars qui je travaillais sur la tête de
ma mère il avait un arbre à pic dans le
cndd il paraît que c'est vrai que les
poils de nez ça protège oui mais on va
passer les implants créé non plus oui oh
oui
et s'il ya un lien entre la nutrition
parce que vous êtes nutritionniste et le
traitement du comité est ce qu'on peut
faire des choses alors il ya une mode
c'est chaud castaldi n'est pas nul hein
premier première on a eu la surprise les
premiers temps en réanimation d'avoir 50
% d'obèses entre 49 et 50 % d'obèses en
réanimation sa poser de problème
1 le problème que c'était beaucoup plus
longs à traiter parce qu'ils ont une
charge virale beaucoup plus importante
et deuxièmement la manipulation c'est à
dire le traitement le nursing était
vachement de rafic et et on avait un
deuxième problème c'est quand il était
en réanimation et c'est là où j'étais
intervenu y perdaient de temps en temps
sur les trois semaines entre 10 et 15 kg
et perdre 10 à 15 kg quand vous êtes un
tube et réanimé et saidal c'est
compliqué donc il a fallu les nourrir de
façon extrêmement particulière avec des
produits compliqués je vais pas en
parler ici sur lequel j'avais besoin
parce que c'était mon domaine d'activité
d'intervenir et c'est comme ça que je
suis devenu progressivement un pro du co
lead grâce à mes copains
on